[Musique]
depuis que je suis tout jeune on dit que
ma famille est
maudite maman essayait de nous protéger
avec Dieu papa voulait nous protéger
avec la lutte il disait que si on était
les plus durs les plus forts rien ne
pouvait nous
atteindre je le croyais on le croyait
tous salut s'il te plaît David enfile un
pantalon je veux que tu rejoignes frère
d' oui monsieur j'adorer ça alors on
sait tous que est mon préféré puis keV
ensuite David et Mike mais le classement
peut toujours changer que veux-tu dans
la vie keV plus de l je veux être avec
ma famille tu sais avec mes
frères et qu'est-ce que tu aimes faire
avec tes
frères
ensemble on peut tout
faire nous sommes ici pour rétablir la
justice au simple la féération de lutte
que notre père a créé de ses propres
mains les mains qui nous a légué les
mains au gripes de fer qui s'agrieront
pour
vous alors tu en penses quoi on est
beaucoup non keV j'adore ta
famille avoir un neveu ouis c'est pas
vrai ça me rend tellement heureux je
peux te dire un truc maman papa est trop
dur avec faut que tu lui parles tes
frères sont là pour ça chérie tu sens ça
tu sens ça c'est ça la
pression je crois que tu pousses trop
loin sérieux k ça va je suis juste
malade j'ai peur mon gars j'ai peur du
contrôle c'était un terrible accident
j'aurais dû l'en empêcher je dois penser
à ma famille ta job c'est d'être lutteur
respecte ton engagement sinon c'est fini
entre nous St qui t'occupé de lui
j'adore être dans le ring avec vous les
gars c'est tout ce qui compte pour moi
la famille mon sera toujours la plus
grande famille dans l'histoire de la
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
L